bonsoir eric laurent journaliste
spécialiste des questions
internationales auteur d' enquête à
succès souvent le dossier secret charbon
en 91 pour dénoncer les dessous de la
guerre du golfe la guerre des bouches
chez plon en 2003 les relations de la
famille bush avec l'entourage de ben
laden et saddam hussein le monde secret
de bouche chez plon en 2004 la religion
les affaires les réseaux occultes la
face cachée du 11-septembre réquisitoire
contre les ambiguïtés américaine et vous
publié aujourd'hui toujours chez plon un
livre qui s'appelle toujours la face
cachée mais cette fois la face cachée du
pétrole alors dans l'avant propos vous
dites l'univers du pétrole est
exactement de la même couleur que ce
liquide tant convoité noir je crois
qu'il faut d'abord expliquer que le
pétrole c'est la clé du monde
contemporain mais mais depuis toujours
c'est à dire que c'est pas seulement une
matière première qu'on extrait se dire
profondément parfois c'est aussi un
certain nombre de secrets de mensonges
et de manipulations qui sont
soigneusement cachée mais depuis des
décennies aux opinions et moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est effectivement de
crocheter les portes et de découvrir la
vérité cachée derrière la réalité
officiel alors vous commencez avec le
fameux choc pétrolier de 1973 et vous
affirmez et c'est un scoop il n'y a
jamais eu de véritable pénurie de
pétrole
les pays producteurs n'ont jamais imposé
leur loi c'est un gigantesque bluff en
fait il s'était secrètement entendu avec
les compagnies pétrolières pour faire
quadruples et le prix en 1960 ont créé
l'opep donc les pays producteurs créé le
pen dans les relations des pays
exportateurs de pétrole entre 1960 et
1973 malgré leurs efforts constants
jamais les pays producteurs ne
réussiront à augmenter même de quelques
centimes le prix du baril c'est
impossible simplement il se passe un
événement considérable 1973 qui passe
totalement inaperçu il ya là un homme
d'ailleurs qui est fine qui a fait une
déclaration qui s'appelle david
rockefeller qui est à l'époque
probablement le personnage le plus
influent du monde des affaires celerity
la dynastie rockefeller et il est le
président de chase manhattan bank et
donc eux aussi le plus gros actionnaire
de dexton la première compagnie mondiale
de pétrole et il dit en 73 en juin 73 à
rome et compagnies pétrolières vont
avoir besoin dans les prochains mois
d'énormément effectivement de 2,2 de
cachou et besoins financiers et chiffre
même sa 3000 milliards de dollars pour
une raison très simple en réalité c'est
qu'à l'époque les grandes compagnies
pétrolières sont dans une situation très
très difficile mais qu'elle cache
soigneusement pourquoi parce qu'elles
ont des investissements énormes à
effectuer notamment en mer du nord et en
mer du nord où il est en effet donc
effectivement dès que la construction de
plates formes offshore très compliqué et
technologiquement très dur et qui coûte
une fortune ces mêmes choses activement
pour la pape laye en alaska qui doit
être construit qu'il a coûté 10
milliards de dollars toutes ces grandes
compagnies sont prises à la gorge est ce
que j'ai découvert c'est qu'elles ont
encouragé les pays producteurs à
augmenter le prix du pétrole est ce que
vous dites eric donc c'est qu'il n'y a
pas eu en fait nous de position
unilatérale de la part des pays
producteurs c'est qu'ils se sont
entendus avec les compagnies pétrolières
pour augmenter les prix ce qui a fait
évidemment la fortune des compagnies
pétrolières qui a fait la fortune et
compagnies pétrolières escaffit
également l'infortuné pays producteurs
mais une forte tempête a fait factice
dans la mesure où ces pays producteurs
de toute façon effectivement nana
n'avait pas les moyens d'absorber ces
surplus pétroliers et c'était encore en
fait un signe de vulnérabilité
supplémentaire parce que ces pays
producteurs ont été contraints de placer
justement leurs excédents pétroliers
dans les grandes banques occidentales
américaine annick et donc elle était
dans les situations de dépendance accrue
dans la mesure où en effet haut du jour
au lendemain les etats unis la grande
bretagne ou les pays occidentaux aurait
pu geler ses avoirs donc ça n'a jamais
été le cartel que l'on raconte et cette
puissance pétrolière que l'on a décrit
jamais c'est un premier en fait c'était
une entente illicite quoi alors avec
laurent vous expliquer comment les usa
ont utilisé l'armé du pétrole saoudien
pour provoquer l'effondrement de l'urss
oui parce que nous sommes en 1981 et
arrive au pouvoir washington donc
l'administration reagan tout le monde se
rappelle les déclarations de reggane l'
axe du mal et est vraiment l'objectif
essentiel c'est vraiment de mettre à bas
donc l'union soviétique et ya une
surtout une découverte qui a été fait
par certains collaborateurs de riga
notamment un que j'ai rencontrés plus en
plus avec rogers robinson crâne
économistes et il a découvert en
comptabilisant effectivement toutes les
rentrées en devises fortes de l'union
soviétique qui un empire il faut le
rappeler gigantesque l époque j est ce
que tous les rentrées en devises sortir
les ventes d'armes les ventes d'or les
ventes de diamants et surtout les ventes
de pétrole n'aboutissent qu'à des
recettes de 24 à 26 milliards de dollars
ce qui peut paraître comme ans les
normes et syriens 24-26 mire deux heures
c'est même pas le tiers du chiffre
d'affaires d'une entreprise comme exxon
ou le moitié du chiffre d'affaires d'une
entreprise comme general motors est
l'idée qui germe effectivement notamment
chez chez un homme qui s'appelle prisée
à l'époque qui le directeur d'assya
c'est de dire en effet voilà on va
demander à l'arabie saoudite d'inonder
est totalement je dire le marché mondial
en pétrole de façon à faire chuter
complètement les cours et la halle à
l'union soviétique s'effondrera sera
asphyxié économiquement et ça va durer
deux ans et négociation de pression et
c'est au bout de deux ans les saoudiens
saad et du jour au lendemain en fin du
jour au lendemain en quelques mois les
cours évidemment chute et l'union
soviétique gorbatchev reconnaît après
d'ailleurs est totalement asphyxiés
alors vous expliquez que l'arabie
saoudite aujourd'hui et ça c'est
vraiment le grand scoop du bouquin voit
ses gisements arrivé à terme vous dites
c'est un secret mais c'est pas trente ou
quarante ans de réserve qu'il y a dans
le sous sol saoudien mais seulement 3 ou
s'est pas beaucoup non c'est très peu et
surtout mais c'est ce qui est une chose
assez fascinante c'est que tous les
chiffres par exemple concernant le
pétrole et les réserves prouvées ses
réserves prouvées ce sont les réserves
qui sont les réserves soit disant
officielle sur lesquels nous basons
notre croissance et notre source ce sont
des chiffres faux mais totalement faux
pour une raison très simple c'est que en
1986 par un simple jeu d'écriture c'est
à dire par une manipulation comptable
les pays de l'opep ont décidé
d'augmenter de 65 % le montant de leurs
réserves de pétrole mais sans qu'il y
ait une nouvelle découverte par exemple
en arabie saoudite la dernière
découverte pétrolière importante remonte
à 1967 simplement c'était bon pour des
raisons aussi financière parce qu'il
s'agisse l'augmenter leurs quotas de
production de valoriser effectivement
donc leur production davantage et donc
c'est ce qu'on découvre c'est que marion
l'arabie saoudite qui a soi disant 260
milliards
il donc dans son sous sol et qui en
avait que 150 milliards avancés
manipulations comptables de 1986
médailles d'or une situation totalement
mais totalement artificielle
vous allez sur le grand champ par
exemple les puits pétroliers en arabie
saoudite 90% des pays pétroliers se sont
représentés 90% de la production
saoudienne est représentée par sept
champs pétroliers le plus grand d'entre
eux s'appelle gaouar et il fait 250 km
de long c'est le plus grand champ
pétrolier au monde il est dans un
produit enfin il est exploité depuis
1948 et aujourd'hui les saoudiens pour
arriver encore à faire jaillir du
pétrole de ce champ effectivement sont
obligés d'injecter tous les jours c'est
une technique sont obligés d'injecter
tous les jours 7 millions de mètres
cubes d'eau pour maintenir une pression
suffisamment fort pour faire jaillir ce
pétrole auraient autrement il y en
aurait plus et la vérité c'est que quand
vous discutez avec les gens de l'aramco
l'aramco c'est le consortium pétrolier
qui avant d'être nationalisées était
dirigée par les américains comme
discothèques des pétroliers américains
ils vous disent il y a environ nous
avons toujours considéré qu'il y avait
130 à 140 ou 150 milliards de barils de
pétrole saoudien et tout le monde tombe
d'accord aujourd'hui pour reconnaître
les chiffres officiels pour dire il y à
100 milliards justement de pétrole
saoudien qui a déjà été extraits alors
cette le compte il risque près 50
milliards de barils il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui 50 milliards de barils
c'est même pas deux années de production
en arabie saoudite yahoo alors mais le
vrai problème est là c'est que nous
sommes dans une situation historique
sans précédent depuis 1973 nous avons
fort et partout tout le monde tombe
d'accord pour dire qu'aujourd'hui on
peut trouver encore du pétrole montrera
plus de grands gisements géants sur
lesquels nous avons tablé effectivement
notre croissance de prospérer à perdre à
jean-françois en fait oui on est il
centrale en particulier jean revient
justement d'asie centrale vous prenez le
cas de la mer caspienne ont suscité par
jean françois kahn l'ouzbékistan
l'ouzbékistan impasse absolue on a cru
que c'était effectivement un eldorado
pétrolier le kazakhstan à côté je veux
dire on a fait vingt entre 20 25 forages
les les trois quarts sont avérés
négatifs ya simplement deux champs
pétrolifères donc vous dites que les
réserves de pétrole en fait sont
beaucoup moins importante que ce qu'on
nous raconte en gros quoi il ya un
énorme bluff que l'administration bush
est parfaitement au courant de cette
situation est que derrière dès son
entrée en fonctions bush avait prévu
avait planifié qui est d'embellir l'irak
il ya une carte qui date de mars 2001
c'est à dire quelques mois avant le 11
septembre que vous avez vu où on voit
huit zones d'exploitation de l'irak
comme ça près de la frontière saoudienne
qu'ils ont pensé à un moment que l'irak
allait remplacer l'arabie saoudite comme
producteur de pétrole oui parce que si
une administration en tout cas un pays
au courant de l'état réel des réserves
saoudiennes c'est bien évidemment les
états unis dans la mesure où les
compagnies paix américaine a exploité
pendant des décennies pétrole saoudien
et la chose très surprenante du couvert
c'est qu'en arrivant donc au pouvoir et
à la maison blanche en janvier 2001 ce
qui préoccupe l'administration bush
c'est pas la sécurité c'est pas le
terrorisme ci est en effet l'énergie et
szczesny d'ailleurs a tenu des propos
quand il était encore été d'halliburton
un an auparavant très alarmiste dix ans
dans quelques années nous allons avoir
besoin de 50 millions de barils jour
supplémentaire ou allons-nous les
trouver et la joute d'ailleurs
effectivement de façon confidentielle
l'arabie saoudite ne pourra pas les
produire et que qu'est ce que nous on
découvre qu en janvier 2001 il ya
création d'une commission sur l'énergie
qui est précise et justement par le vice
président cheney et la chose très
surprenante c'est que cette commission
siège dans le plus grand secret on ne
connaît pas le nom des membres on ne
connaît pas l'ordre du jour on ne
connaît pas effectivement les personnes
exactement qui sont qui siègent
effectivement ou qui sont effectivement
appelé devant cette commission au point
qu'une journaliste fort réputé fort
estimé du washington post avec dana
milbank surnomme cette commission la
société secrète et je vous passe les
détails donc un certain nombre de
membres du congrès qui s'alarment se dit
écoutez cette quand même cette
commission fonctionne avec de l'argent
public par conséquent effectivement les
travaux de cette commission doivent être
rendus publics refus de la maison
blanche qui oppose le privilège de
l'exécutif le secret d'exécutive deux
ans de bataille juridique au bout de ces
deux ans de bataille juridique à la
grande fureur de chaîner trois documents
sont son doigt doivent être rendus
publics par ces commissions est l'un des
documents que vous disiez c'est une
carte de l'irak estampillée mars de
ménage est entre les mains où il ya en
effet donc le découpage du tiers du
territoire irakien en ville odon vallet
d'un accord ces huit mois avant le 11
septembre et oui oui absolument une
carte de l'irak avec des zones des
coupes et qui sont donc un substitut à
la production saoudienne oui dans la
mesure où on considère que l'irak est le
deuxième producteur mondial et pourrait
effectivement supplée bien sûr jeu pour
sa part marché oui ça peut marcher ça
c'est autre chose n'a pas marché mais
enfin de là à penser que l'on septembre
a été un prétexte pour s'emparer de
cette zone là y'a pas été en tout cas je
suis de cette tragédie a été une grosse
et d'administration peut-être une divine
surprise oui bien sûr
alors au delà du déclin des ressources
d'arabie saoudite où les chiffres donc
des réserves pétrolières sans faux et le
vrai problème on le voit très bien c'est
que par exemple aujourd'hui pour 6 baril
tous les shows que nous consommons il ya
un seul barils seulement qui aient
découvert ça c'est tout à fait
intéressant ça c'est quand même très
très est par exemple les grandes
compagnies les dix premières compagnies
mondiales donc c'est quand même 20 ont
investi 11 milliards de dollars donc en
frais de recherche et d'investissements
l on trouvait simplement l'équivalent de
4 milliards de dollars de réserves
d'offres de ressources nouvelles c'est
peu il ça me rappelle une pub qu'est ce
que c'était pour un baril en vous
adonnant le pour les valeurs
non mais ce que vous lui dites là comme
ça c'est qu'en fait la cei et c'est la
première fois où il est à peu près
officiel qu'elle a écrit il n'y aura
plus de pétrole mais c'est la première
fois en fait où on se trouve dans une
situation où le déclin mais vraiment
marqué de la production et des réserves
coïncide avec une espèce de mes deux
formidable explosion de la demande et la
consommation mariale avec la chine et
voilà mais quand vous allez en chine à
pékin j'ai rencontré le conseiller pour
le pôle énergie présence ou noir hélas
ce cet homme que le professeur mike est
un homme fort intelligent revenait de
washington il me dit où la chose qui
nous préoccupe c'est pas tellement les
prix du pétrole est hyper ce que ça où
nous sommes en mesure de payer beaucoup
plus cher le vrai problème pour nous et
10 et la sécurité de l'approvisionnement
nous avons la route est longue douze
mille kilomètres absolument et 10 les
américains sont en mesure de couper la
ligne d'approvisionnement quand ils le
veulent et on sent très bien que c'est
une énorme angoisse pour les chinois
c'est que les américains sont présents
en irak y sont présents au moyen-orient
et c'est donc en fait ils tiennent les
ressources pétrolières et les chinois
sont oui j'ai des demandes bien sûr ils
n'ont pensé quoi philippe voilà y aura
plus de pétrole n'ont pas longtemps à
rentrer
je ne sais pas quoi
vous intéressez pas encore aussi de
substitution mais si justement je me
suis intéressé et le vrai problème c'est
qu'on ne trouve pas d'énergie de
substitution qui permettent le pétrole
en fait si c'était la matière première
et voilà c'est d'abord le pouvoir en
plus c'était évidemment elle offrait un
certain nombre de dérives et on est à
trois cent mille dérivés vous rendez
compte nos vêtements par exemple
l'alimentation
et des milliards de dollars consacrés à
la recherche du pétrole qu'elle est quel
est le chiffre clef l'équivalence en
substituant recherche de substituts de
pas beaucoup beaucoup moins mais il
affirme sans taj mais la vérité de
0,00 0 4% pour la storia du tout mais le
vrai problème c'est que pourquoi les
pétroliers ne font pas plus parce qu'ils
savent très bien qu'il n'ya pas de
d'énergie de substitution qui puisse se
substituer au pétrole ouais c'est ça le
vrai problème est le vrai problème au
fond les pétroliers et et quelque part
les produits de producteurs en mentant
sur le montant des réserves sont tout à
fait dans leur rôle mais ce qui est tout
à fait de mon point de vue choquant
c'est justement quelque part le vire le
silence des états des états et des
gouvernements ici je trouve que c'est
impardonnable et quelque part
aujourd'hui on a on a un lobby pétrolier
qui aujourd'hui 2 oui mais c'est pas
seulement ça mais qui devient plus
alarmistes aujourd'hui que les
gouvernements par exemple vous avez vous
regardé le dernier rapport d'exxon exxon
commence à dire vous savez nous sommes à
une période de déclin rapide de la
production il faut se préparer à
l'après-pétrole ne sont pas de quelle
manière avec bon bref silence
assourdissant des gouvernements la
phrase d'henri queuille sur vos
américains y aurait cueille qui était
une grande figure de la quatrième
république disait il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas de problème politique si complexe
soit-il qui ne puisse être réglée par
une absence de décision politique est
bien là je crois qu'il se trompe c'est
tout et le vrai problème est là
aujourd'hui c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
politiques sont complètement je dire
absents et hatton par exemple agence
internationale de l'énergie qui a
toujours été une agence qui réunit les
principaux pays industrialisés qui a
toujours été une agence extrêmement info
ricketts et présentant une vision est
vraiment une très optimiste 40 50 années
pétrole aujourd'hui tout est réalisé par
exemple le chef économiste fatih birol
je racontais il ya une anecdote l'année
dernière il ya un congrès sur l'énergie
ce type qui est qu un type brillant
prononce un discours très convenue et
puis descend de la tribune et puis se
met à parler avec quelques délégués en
disant de toute façon si l'arabie
saoudite n'est pas en mesure de produire
3 millions de barils supplémentaires
nous courons à la catastrophe savait
très difficile et à ce moment là une
liste de vie mystique et à côté qui lui
dit et vous pensez que heidi vous êtes
journaliste sait pas pour vous et la
journaliste bbc fait le tour des
délégués vous pensez que l'arabie
saoudite peut représenter effectivement
une alternative et les délégués
répondent 3 millions de barils jour
c'est impensable la varicelle l'arabie
saoudite ne peut même plus produire 300
mille barils supplémentaires or voilà et
cet homme cette île virol à une phrase
merveilleuse il a dit le pétrole c'est
qu'une petite amie vous savez un jour
qu'elle va vous quitter qu'elle va vous
briser le coeur d'eau qui au mieux vaut
mieux la quitter avant faut faire la
même chose avec le pétrole
j'ai plongé à béziers et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de in a l'habitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux